so tell us a little bit about how Pearl
got started
um it's a strange story because we were
heading to New Zealand to make X and we
were making in New Zealand because it
was the peak of the pandemic and New
Zealand was a safe place to make movies
and we had spent all this effort
organizing a crew there bringing in a
crew getting visas
um
and we were building a barn and a bunk
house and really kind of redesigning the
layout of a home in in wanganui New
Zealand and that's a lot of effort and a
lot of money and a lot of time and it
was a very uncertain time when it was
amazing we were fortunate enough to even
be able to make a movie and it wasn't
obvious we'd ever be able to do it again
so for me I felt like we've gone to New
Zealand we put all this effort in could
we use this stuff to make anything else
with it rather than just make a movie
tear it down and go home and wonder
about our future so
I felt like we were so fortunate to have
the opportunity to be there that we
should try to make the most of it and so
then I was trying to think of well how
would we do that and I didn't want to
make a sequel where just more people
went to the farm and died that didn't
sound very interesting and
I have been spending a lot of time
talking to Mia goth about the character
of pearl because she was playing Maxine
in Pearl and x and I wanted to make sure
that I knew who Pearl was because even
though we catch up with her very late in
life and acts and she's the villain in
that movie if me it was to ever ask well
why is she this or why is she that I
didn't want to not have an answer so I
had a backstory idea for Pearl already
and we started talking about it
and that occurred to me that like that
actually could be the movie where we
could you know cannibalize everything
we're doing and amortize all these costs
and we could make a second movie about
young Pearl because she's the villain in
the first movie but she could be the
star of another movie and age 24 was
intrigued by that and then off I went to
New Zealand and I had two weeks in
mandatory quarantine that's a long time
to be stuck in a room and I called Mia
and I said like if we come up with a
second movie and it's good and a24 was
willing to make it would you stick
around and be in a second movie she said
yes and so I said well let's collaborate
on it and let's do it together because
you are pearls there's no pearl without
you and we would FaceTime while I was in
that hotel room and cranked out a script
and when we got out of the hotel room I
sent today 24 and they liked it and they
were like give us a minute to decide so
we started prepping X and getting
everything ready and as we prepped X I
showed them how we could do Pearl and
how it would be different and how if we
if we got the okay now we could do it
very inexpensively because we would be
able to you know get ahead of everything
they really liked the script and they
you know in an amazing moment in total
credit to them they bet on the movie and
they greenlit Pearl before we even shot
X and so we were able to finish prepping
acts and make x with the knowledge we
were going to make Pearl and then we had
three weeks in between the two movies to
like
completely retrofit the the location
um but it was a very you know it was
almost like making one big movie and I'm
incredibly fortunate that that that's
how it worked out and it's
you know it's led to now you know a
movie we had
totally secret for a year and then
to be able to announce it the way we did
and do the same thing now as Maxine has
been really fun
how did you manage to keep it a secret
of all that time
I don't know I mean I in 2022 it's a
really legit question because I'm not
sure but I think
we just I mean the short answer is we
didn't tell anybody unless you worked on
the movie you all know nothing and that
was how we just we were very adamant
about don't put it on IMDb and no
announcements and just keep it a secret
at what point did you know that Mia goth
would be a good collaborator not just as
far as as collaborating on the character
of pearl but with the script and as a
producer and everything I didn't know I
just I had been having a lot of really
conversations with her and like I said I
felt like we were going to make a story
about Pearl and she was going to play
Pearl and X
it's not like there'd be another actor
to do it with it was like if she's she
had said no I can't spend three more
months in New Zealand I would have just
given up you know because it was it was
going to be her movie and I felt like
to start doing that and to know her at
the time that I did and have been
working on this character with her it
like it didn't make sense to not do it
that way so I didn't know if she would
be helpful not helpful any I didn't know
I just thought like it was the right
thing to do is to say well from
conception let's do this together and
then she ended up being really great I
mean I'm not shocked we obviously got
along very well and she had great ideas
so it was like I wasn't shocked I
wouldn't have done it if I thought oh
this could be really bad but I just you
know it just seemed like
she's Pearl so she needs to be involved
in the Pro movie from the conception
what did you have any contingency plan
if she hadn't been good a good
collaborator
well we wouldn't have made the movie
okay yeah I mean there was no shortage
of reasons to not make the movie you
know what I mean like it's so
unbelievably rare that it actually
happened so which is which is amazing
but there was a many moments where it
could have not happened and I suppose
yes it had been some sort of disaster
that would have been one of them but I
mean I didn't ever think it would be
that but I also just knew like we wanted
to do it so bad that we would we would
get it done and we would make it to the
Quality we needed to because we weren't
doing it just to do it we really wanted
to make it like a great movie out of it
can you talk about some of the long
shots that you had with Mia goth
especially
um like the law the final
um her final monologue with Mitzi and um
also the end credits where she's just
got that huge almost demonic smile
across her face and she's holding it and
it looks like she's almost in pain can
you just talk about working with her
through those long shots well the end
credits
um the day that we filmed that that was
not necessarily going to be a
three-minute take of that
um it was just supposed to be that she
says the line and I knew it was going to
be like she would smile and it was going
to freeze frame and say the end just
like how in the beginning it freeze
frames when she beats the goose to the
alligator and it says Pearl and that was
the plan and then when we set up to film
it
I don't know we've made it much of the
movie at that point and I was kind of
used to her performance and I just I had
a random idea where I was like Hey when
we do this if you can smile and I want
to freeze frame I was like but
I'm curious what would happen if we just
like organically Freeze Frame like if
you just tried to hold it and she was
like okay and I was like and just see
how long you can hold the smile and you
know just if you can't hold it anymore
just stop and whatever but let's just do
it because I can always Freeze Frame
anywhere in there but let's see what
happens
and so
we set up we did that she smiled that's
what happened for three minutes I said
cut and I was like that's amazing that's
going to be The Incredibles of the movie
and we'd only did it that one time wow
because it was just like I watched it
the same way anyone that sees the movie
I had that experience watching it
because she didn't know she was doing
that I didn't know she was gonna do that
it just happened and I was like this is
great it was unbelievable and I mean
just in the theater last night people
were just laughing and wincing and it
was crazy yeah it's a wild moment so it
ended up being one of those kind of very
fortuitous things that that came
together yeah the movie it's more of an
Ode to Classic Cinema than it is really
a an out and out horror film do you
worry that it will drive away horror
fans
I mean I don't know if it's going to
drive anyone away I mean you know if
you're coming to the movie for
an enormous body count at all times like
yeah you're gonna get a different kind
of movie than that but I I think it
delivers in its own way and I think that
you know for anyone who is not for
there's another person that it is for
you know and so perhaps who may not see
X because they think whoa porn harder
that's just slash that's too much I
can't deal with that maybe this is a
movie that they can actually you know
really get behind and appreciate because
it's it is not you know what they're
afraid of and uh Pearl was quite a
sympathetic character she was in X and
she's even more so in in her own movie
um was that always the plan or was that
kind of something that sprung up
organically it was the plan I mean most
of that's credit to Mia
um her performance but I think
even yeah we never really wanted to we
wanted to be in her perspective in the
movie so we wanted to portray her like
honestly and genuinely and you know
there's always there's a point in the
movie when she goes to a dance audition
and virtually everybody's rooting for
her despite the many horrible things
she's done in the movie and that's that
is a testament to her performance and
it's a testament to like just treating
the character
as a relatable person despite the
demented and awful things she's doing
you can't really vouch for it but you
can understand it and that that was
always the goal is to put you in her in
her shoes so now you've got Maxine
coming out
um was this always planned as a Trilogy
um well it wasn't really planned as
anything and then we planted as a movie
called X and then once Pearl got
involved
I did tell a24 about the idea for Maxine
once I had that idea because I started
to have the idea for all three when I
had Pearl and they liked the idea for
Maxine and they were like we'd be
interested in making that movie and I
was like well we have to go back before
we can go forward because you know the
Maxine as a sequel to X is fine Maxine
is part three of three different movie
inspired
stories is better and so if we had not
made pro and just I don't know that I
would have made Maxine because just
making Maxine like the vibe of Maxine is
very different than x just like Pearl is
very different from X and it would have
perhaps been strange to kind of carry
forward and have it segue into something
unexpected whereas now that it's part of
this Trilogy it will make more sense
what that idea is okay what is the vibe
of Maxine men
I'm not going to tell you yeah
he's just one movie a secret for a year
this other one for six months I think
I'm just gonna keep going with you know
we'll we'll show up with the movie when
we do and and you know no the less you
know the better do you uh have an idea
of when it will be released
yes okay you're gonna keep that a secret
too yes all right okay
um
can you talk a little bit about what it
was like scoring with the sweeping
Orchestra yeah I mean Tyler Bates who
did x with Chelsea Wolfe we had a really
we had a great experience we had done
the sacrament together before and him
and Chelsea did an amazing job on X and
Tyler was down to do two movies
um and I think he and maybe everyone
expected it would be not the same as X
but you know in the ballpark and X is a
very stripped down vocal driven kind of
thing
um and then as Pro came together I was
like I know you signed on to do two with
us but uh here's the thing
um we're gonna need to do like a giant
Orchestra for it and that's so much more
work and the thing is
um with Tyler he's the hardest working
person I know and Tyler also really
believes in whatever he's working on he
believes in it to the extent like he's
doing it because he wants to do it and I
remember telling him and he was right
okay and then we just got to work and
then he brought in uh Tim Williams to do
it with him because we had to do that
whole score in two months from writing
it to recording it to mixing it and it
was a live Orchestra 60 piece Orchestra
and so
um it's really remarkable that they were
able to do that I mean it's such a
character in the movie and it's so
unlike anything that's out now and it
really you know contextualizes the movie
in this sort of like cinematic way so
when you go and watch this movie I mean
movies don't have 85 minutes of Music in
them anymore and certainly not requested
music like that so it was a real treat
to be able to do it was this the first
time you had ever worked with a score
like that an orchestral score
at that scale yes I have done live
string sections before and live drums
and horns and things like that but I've
done them sort of in small chunks and
put them together this was a full 65
piece like everyone in the room kind of
thing it was amazing yeah they did an
amazing job yeah
um okay I think that's all I've got for
you
um but thank you I really enjoyed it and
I'm looking forward to Maxine
um I'll get back to you yes please do
and uh enjoy your string cheese uh it's
already gone but yeah okay we'll have
some more so thank you okay good all
right thank you so much